we're here with women's band master
Camilla bag and sky tea Camilla in the
past couple of years you've done pretty
well here at the u.s. women's Chess
Championships why do you do so well
first tournament maybe it's good sided
see there's some sort of surprise so
you're surprised by your own success
even though you kind of kind of do you
feel like luck plays a part in the games
at all or do you feel like it's only a
skill based game they look for places
party so but I would say that in many
cases service so it's about keeping a
level head now you cook you're traveling
here from South Dakota which is not
really known as a chess Mecca is that
hard to say in game form when you're in
around and it's always a big decision
that is so should I go should I not go
because I'm so said nearest victor and
I'm a trophy by the race I know that
when any of the players here suffers a
tough defeat it's very very hard
how do you recover mentally from a bad
game when you know you've got another
game that counts just as much the next
day
I usually try not to take it too
seriously so it's it's especially
dangerous now such computers are so
prominent I'm so to take you seriously
means hours and hours of work with
computer and - name so I'm a bit afraid
of that now your background is an art is
that right yes there aren't too many
chess players that are art educators do
you know of any others that have a
career I'm so out somebody but I forgot
what the name wasn't so but at least
that's participating so I I'm not
strictly speaking an artist thing so I
have a degree in art history nothing but
the into this it's an unusual
combination this year gonna have two
more rounds than last year because there
are two more competitors do you think
the length of the tournament would would
help a younger player or do you feel
like you're up to the challenge of
playing nine rounds in a mechanics game
so I don't sense a Yanks he has a very
big impact in this case because we have
a lot of three days and most of all time
so we do not have Armageddon chess which
I believe Emma saw was a very good
factor I'm so in
bringing more tiredness class together
so it's interesting the faster the game
even though the game takes less time it
takes more out of the player it sounds
like well yes I'm so besides is a fail
well I wish you well here at the Women's
Tennis Championships we hope you win one
and there's under your chest fans
looking forward to seeing your games
thank you very much